so uh
rich spoke a couple days ago about the
value of self-imposed constraints
uh swears is the subset of closure with
no alphanumeric characters
this expression here computes seven
factorial
so the primary researchers on this
project are tim mccormick and
john nicholas laronge and most of the
com the content in this presentation
comes from them
so what sorts of things can we express
in swearsier
to start with we can get any positive
integer we like starting with the fact
that the multiplication function returns
one if you don't pass any arguments so
you can add these ones together
and then multiply those larger numbers
and get anywhere you need to with that
you can get negative integers and ratios
using the negation function
and the division function we don't know
any way to get floats if we could get a
single floating point number presumably
we could get the rest of them
but i don't know of any way to do this
yet
true true and false are pretty easy with
the equals function
and nil we can get by calling an empty
hash map with something that's not in it
um data structures are interesting most
of this is based on what you can do with
the backtick
so on line three we can cons something
onto a list by using a backtick
quoted list and then unquoting a single
element and unquote splicing a sequence
you can concat two things by unquote
splicing both of them
we can convert stuff to a vector by
unquote splicing it inside the vector
and we can do something mostly like inf
by converting it to a vector first and
calling that vector using an
integer in the style from the previous
slide so this requires that your
sequences can all fit in memory nicely
[Music]
functions are where it gets really
interesting um because the only
function literal we can use is this
reader literal
we can't use fun and defund for obvious
reasons
and even within sight of this we can
only refer to the first argument and the
rest of the arguments we can't refer to
the other positions
but that turns out to be okay because we
can always take the rest and stick them
in a vector and call that
and really crucially we can't nest these
so uh one problem that comes up is how
could you return
a data structure literal from one of
these functions you can't just stick it
in there like on line one because it'll
try to call it
you can do this with fun but we can't
use fun
you could call identity but you can't
call identity
but what you can do is you can stick it
into a vector and then call that vector
immediately and pull it back out
so this is a useful tactic
other common closure core functions ink
and deck are pretty easy
um identity uses uh the tactic from the
previous slide put the argument in a
vector and then pull it back out
boolean is quite useful for when you
need to simulate if
um fortunately you can you can create a
map of all of the falsie values
and then call that map with true as the
not found value so that lets you convert
something into a boolean
line five is the high level version and
line six is the actual version
um so for control flow and recursion
um the best tactic so far is to use a
function table all this code is high
level of course but
hopefully a somewhat straightforward
translation into real squares here
the idea is that all the functions that
you might call you you stick them in a
map
and then that map is your function table
and gets passed into every function as
the first argument and that function can
you know do a few things and decide what
it wants to call next and then pull the
function out of the map
and call it with the function table
again and whatever else it wants to pass
in
you can use this to simulate if so
on line six here we're calling if
with the in less than 5
expression so we pass that into the
hashmap to get a key
that we look up in the function table to
get the next function we want to
call and then call that with the
function table and
the other argument so this is
pretty useful however it eats the stack
pretty badly
every time you call another function
you're adding something to the stack and
you never get that back
so when we use swears are in production
we just try not to think about this too
much
other interesting things this version of
map is is really interesting uh we're
doing the stick of thing in a vector and
pull it back out tactic here
but inside the vector we have a back
quoted
hash map literal and at the syntactic
level this has two things in it
but if you're calling this function with
say eight things four keys and four
values
what you're gonna end up doing is is
unquoting the first key
as the key in this map and the other
seven things
as the value and it somehow expands out
and you get the correct hash map so
that's really weird
um also you can get a gen sim just for
fun
and and this expression computes a
constant gen sim so every time you call
it you get the same one so it's not very
useful as a gen sim but if you like
looking at gen sims
you can get them if you have this this
function literal in several places
you'll get a different gen sim in each
place that you create it but
also tim implemented uh rest
which is a useful function to have uh
this basically does some sort of weird
recursive thing with a vector where it
walks through the whole thing to build
up the rest of it
i
yeah so it's a little tedious but it
works
um so what are what are the limits of
what we can do um is it turing complete
the first thought everybody has is well
it's just lame to calculus right
well that's not so obvious actually
because we can't nest things they're not
really closures
so i don't think there's any
straightforward reduction there however
i've become about 98
convinced that we can implement the ski
calculus if we want to
i would have done it myself but i don't
have time so
please let me know how that goes
um is it closure complete
hardly there's lots of things we're
missing there's things we can't express
like floating point numbers and
other things we can't do java interop
lots of higher order stuff and other
host things basically everything we
can't do
so we're left with the inescapable
conclusion that swearser is basically
useless
but still surprisingly powerful um
so work and swears ongoing if you're
using it in production then please let
us know how it works
there are lots of ways to help for
example we need help strategizing
with how to sneak changes into closure
that makes swears are more powerful
so that's all i have thank you very much